Britain's rather official warning for
Queen Elizabeth has ended it ended
overnight but for the Royals themselves
it will last another week giving them
some private time after that public
display of grief at the Queen's funeral
Charlie dagada has more now from outside
Windsor Castle scene of the final
moments of a day filled with pageantry
the long walk back home
emotional crowds watch the coffin pass
by the final road to her final resting
place at Windsor Castle hundreds of
thousands of people line the route from
Westminster Abbey to Windsor to bid the
queen farewell
procession passed by her Pony Carlin
Lima Emma and waiting at the castle her
beloved corgis Sandy and Vic
one last televised service inside St
George's Chapel before the private
burial the dean of Windsor David Connor
acknowledging a nation entering a new
era her calm and dignified presence
has given us confidence
face the future as she did with courage
and with hope the king who will now
Reign showing the strains of both losing
his mother and taking on her role heavy
is the head that wears the crown King
Charles watched as the instruments of
State the crown the orb the scepter were
removed from the coffin the country
enters a new phase an uncertain future
without the one constant most here have
ever known
while her subjects make way for the new
king he's a quintessential British
gentleman so what more could you want a
day full of pageantry and high emotions
no Nation on Earth does ascend-off like
this one it was impressive to see the
entire country
mobilize in in such a way we don't have
that reverence for our leaders in
America
the queen finally laid to rest beside
her husband Prince Philip
but the memory and the mark Her Majesty
made on this country will never ever be
forgotten
[Music]
Charles became king the moment his
mother died but the coronation the days
actually crowned well that takes place
late spring or early summer next year he
is expected to take up residents at
Buckingham Palace this will become his
weekend retreat okay
as usual thank you for your coverage
Charlie dagada and Windsor